hey guys thanks tuning in
so trying to record a video on the force
facing camera for a change not sure how
it's gonna pan out but I'll give it a go
so apologies if the quality isn't as
good as usual we'll find out so today
I'm gonna talk to you about new trade
picks that's smart drugs I'm gonna talk
in a bit of detail about how they work
whether you should use them what the
best ones are what the stock I use is
and my thoughts in general on the topic
in the past on this channel I've
reviewed things like modafinil Baraka
Tom and still tip and I've talked about
my thoughts on it whether or not I use
it but I haven't talked in general about
nootropics what they are etc so I
thought I'd go over that in a bit more
detail and tell you why I use the
supplements that I do use because if you
watch those videos you'll know that I
think not to use those ones that I just
pointed out with the exception of maybe
still Tet in small doses so basically
neutral mixes supplements or drugs or
even foods that improve your brain power
in one or multiple regards so these work
in a variety of different ways but the
ones like that the ones I just mentioned
with ethanol etc and the ones that are
often most popular they work by altering
levels of neurotransmitters so basically
your brain is made up of billions of
neurons which are cells and they're all
connected you probably know this it
looks kind of like a mind map there are
web of interconnected spider Tindall
things and each one of these represents
some kind of experience and when they
fire you experience that stimuli so for
instance should a neuron in your
occipital your visual cortex your
occipital lobe Yorke's your visual
cortex fire then you'll experience like
a pixel light up so that new on
literally corresponds with that pixel
likewise if something was to file if the
New Orleans to fire within your auditory
cortex you hear a slight sound but of
course they all do lots of different
things they can also map memories so
should particularly neuron fire then you
might remember a smell you might
remember a color or something that
happened of course most memories are the
results of
multiple connections all firing at once
and that's why when we think of one
thing often reminded of another thing
because it's all kind of interconnected
like this and as you learn you form new
neural connections and new neurons
that's called neurogenesis which was
thought to be impossible until
relatively recently this is the basis of
brain plasticity and it's how memory
works the formation of new connections
and also the growth of new neurons so
when you see something and you want to
remember it your brain will create a
little connection the more often you
repeat that experience too often you
think of it or experience it the
stronger that connection will get over
something called long term potentiation
and the stronger gets the easier is to
remember so that's all I sound like a
little bit of nonsense but ultimately
you're left this big massive web of
interrelated ideas and thoughts and that
is pretty much your personality it's
also the sum of all your memories is how
you learn is how you concentrate is how
you experience things and it's called a
connectome and some personality
theorists say that we are our connectome
so that's a very basic look at how the
brain works and that's what you need to
know to know how these new tricks work
because you see when new on fires and a
connection lights up it's not just
binary it's not just on or off it can
also contain information about that
firing and this is where the
neurotransmitters come in which are tiny
chemicals a little bit like hormones and
they are contained in something called
neuro vesicles which are the end of each
neuron at the synapse which is the gap
where it where it has to travel across
when it's sound communicating with
another neuron so what happens is it
fires through an electrical charge it
releases neurotransmitters and they go
to the next neuron and this then tells
you things like whether or not what
happened was important whether or not it
makes you happy or whether it makes me
sad so it's the kind of emotional
content and it's also the content that
tells your brain how to deal with it
like this is important I need to focus
on it so dopamine is the
neurotransmitter related with attention
and focus and activation and when that
fires you like your brain is like this
is important I need to look at it and I
remember it so if it's a lion you get a
bunch of dopamine just like this is a
memorable experience I need to think
about it you also get a bunch of
norepinephrine which is essentially like
adrenaline and that gives you more focus
and it takes your attention away from
other things and amps up your system
it's what's responsible for the
fight-or-flight response and then you
have other neurotransmitters like
serotonin which is to do with happiness
as all the other endorphins you have
things like a sitar choline which is to
do with learning you have things like
melatonin which is to do with sleep so
basically they all do different things
and depending on which new transmitters
are released that dictates how you
respond how you behave how you learn so
what the neurotransmitter what the
nutrient picks do is to mimic the
effects of these neurotransmitters to
enhance them to suppress them you've got
one of the identities everyone like
Garba gamma makes you feel sleepy it's
one of the ones that tells us when it's
time to go to sleep and inhibits and the
activity of neurons so some new
transmitters work suddenly tricks work
by blocking or suppressing the release
of gaba one more thing you do today I'm
really throwing some information at you
here I hope I'm explaining it all right
is that when when the neurons fire you
have one end and it releases the new
your transmitters across this gap that
I've said it's called the synapse to the
other end and at the other end you have
the receptors receptors where the newer
transmitters fit in and it's kind of
like one of those games that kids used
to play with with the round pegs and the
round holes and the square pegs and
square holes in other words you need to
have the right receptors for the right
neurotransmitters to fit into so if you
have more receptors than you can have
more of an effect from the
neurotransmitters if you have fewer
receptors then you can have less of an
effect so in other words you can't just
keep amping up a certain amount of a new
transmitter - it needs to have the
receptors to go into and likewise when
the new your transmitters are just
floating around are they're useless
they get really up taken the reuptake
occurs through transporters which
basically clean up your unwanted
neurotransmitters so the reason I'm
telling you all this is because some
nootropics work by blocking the reuptake
the transporters they mimic the
appearance of neurotransmitters they
block the transporters and this music
then have more of that neurotransmitter
in your brain this is the same way that
antidepressants work say for instance
you have serotonin reuptake inhibitors
SSRIs and they work by blocking the
serotonin transporter which means
there's more certain in your brain which
basically floods you with you know good
feeling and the same thing is how a lot
of recreational drugs work so for
instance if you have to use something
like cocaine that works by suddenly I
think I've got the right one here oh no
I'm thinking of MDMA it works by
releasing all of the this is ecstasy
works by releasing all of the new
transmitters dopamine serotonin and I
believe and norepinephrine from the
vesicles in your brains you just get
suddenly flooded with them it's very
dangerous
I'm gonna explain why so basically
nootropics work in a very similar way to
these but they're slightly less potent
effect otherwise they'd probably be
illegal and also they're obviously
focusing on the new transmitters that
you want to use in order to make
yourself brighter better learner so for
instance barakatuh increases
acetylcholine through one means and
another modafinil increases dopamine and
norepinephrine and so does caffeine good
old caffeine works by increasing
dopamine and these increase your focus
they increase your attention because
you've got more of the new more of the
neurotransmitter in your brain that
tells your brain this is important this
needs to be learned I need to remember
this and thus you get this kind of focus
this attention and you can learn and you
can work that's the theory this is how
most nootropics work a lot of the ones
people want admiral still tet so except
also increases dopamine among other
things but the problem is with
increasing neurotransmitter is that a
the brain responds through something
called tolerance and dependence so say
you're increasing this is why you also
shouldn't use recreational drugs because
it's very dangerous it changes your
brain chemistry basically you keep
increasing the amount of available new
transmitter in your brain so you keep
flooding your brain with dopamine
your brain says right well I've got too
much dopamine I don't need that much and
so it gets rid of some of the dopamine
receptors which means you've now need
more doping to have the same effect on
the brain that you used to so in other
words you start to become tolerant to
the substance that you're using and also
when you're not using it you now have
less dopamine so actually you're taking
this new tribute to try and make
yourself more focused but in the rest of
the time you become less focused and
just to feel back to normal you need it
and that's why many drugs like like
cocaine little increase they feel good
hormones in your brain and new
transmitters but then it means that the
rest of the time you are working a
deficit and you're just trying to get
back up to that normal level and of
course that's a bad thing a lot of
supplements people use for smart drugs
like modafinil they say I'm not
addictive you don't have the issues of
tolerance and dependence but I can't see
this as being the case I mean even if
you increase dopamine naturally through
in behavior even by just watching porn
then your brain changes and you do get
tolerance and dependence so to say that
something like modafinil won't cause
that I don't see how someone can say
that from my own experiences I did try
it just to review yeah I could see how
you could easily be convicted something
like that and psychologically if not in
any other way
at the same time they also don't know
how a lot of these new tricks work so
say Baraka town it increases a sitar :
which increases attention and learning
but at the same time they don't actually
know precisely how it's increasing a
sitar Cohen and to me that's the warning
sign as a reg red-flag and I hope they
haven't been studied in that long term
to know that they're completely safe so
that's another reason I don't recommend
that one at the same time there are
neurotransmitters we haven't even
discovered yet and they don't work in a
vacuum
you can't just increase one and expect
that to change if you increase dopamine
you increase norepinephrine why because
your brain says this is important and so
it also says I need to focus so it
changes the levels of everything and
when one hormone goes up then another
one goes up so if you increase a
feel-good hormone often your brain would
also increase like cortisol the stress
hormone just in order to bring it up to
that normal level cortisol will also
increase when you use a nootropic like
modafinil
or even a caffeine to increase dopamine
and norepinephrine it's the stress
hormone it makes you worried and that's
where you get that jittery anxious
feeling when you use a lot of these kind
of things are supposed to boost
attention and finally you can't improve
your brain by simply improve
one neurotransmitter anyways because for
instance there's no such thing as the
best way for your brain to behave so say
you increased dopamine that's great for
increasing focus but actually there was
evidence there which can meet up my blog
I've talked about in more detail to
suggest that increasing your focus
actually decreases creativity because
creativity occurs when you're relaxed
when you know when a in your real flow
State I think Ananda mite is the new
transmitter that increases that what you
need is for your brain to just wander to
just explore all these different ideas
so in that happens when you're relaxed
when you're focused you're only looking
at the very kind of strong connections
you're focusing on specific neurons but
when you're relaxed then you're able to
spread out and look and you find
connections that you didn't see before
like the way that maybe one idea is
connected to another this critter new
idea a lot of people think that's where
ideas come from it's the connectors just
you making new connections between
existing thoughts in your brain so the
point is you can increase focus but then
you're going to decrease creativity and
likewise if you take something to
increase creativity you're going to
decrease focus so you know you there's
no one way you need to be your brain
needs to be able to flit from one thing
to another
so just elevating one new transmitter is
actually a fool's errand so with all
that in mind do I think new traffic so a
stupid idea shouldn't do them it sounds
like it but no actually that's not I'm
saying
for starters at least nootropics are
trying to target the correct new trend
list at least they're trying to improve
your brain we dragged ourselves all the
time in various different ways
a alcohol for instance and we know
that's bad for us we're not even trying
to improve our brain so don't like have
a massive go at people like oh you know
nutrifix is so dangerous you're messing
with your new transmitter as well yeah
yeah oh and when you have a cup of tea
or when you drink alcohol as well at
least new tricks is trying to do the
right thing so I'm not saying I'm
demonizing you're not saying it's really
dangerous and some people they swear by
modafinil that's right for them great
cool keep using it if you want it's also
illegal unless it's on prescription so
that's always something to consider but
that's the one thing the second thing is
that there are other types of noot noot
nootropics
that work in a different way and those
are much safer and in my opinion
much better way of going about it
because like I've said what you really
you're going to build to do is to switch
for its attention from one thing to
another and in doing so release the
neurotransmitters that are appropriate
for that thing and this comes down to
basically mental discipline your passion
for what you're doing how focused and
switched-on you are and also just your
brains health like the ability that it
has to send signals across synapse is
the amount of energy it has how well
slept you are and this is how you really
improve your brain and the great thing
about this is it also improves your
general health and it's protective
against neurogenic neurodegenerative
diseases come on all the things I've
said and that's one I struggle with so
basically now they'll kind of your
nutrifix that I recommend are all the
ones that focus on increasing the
communication between your neurons
increasing the amount of energy your
brain is capable of using etc so for
instance creatine creatine is a
supplement that is used by bodybuilders
often as well as athletes to get more
energy but it also has been shown in
studies to help improve performance on
IQ tests on short-term memory tests all
these things so what is in creatine
creatine is basically a substance that
allows your cells to recycle adenosine
triphosphate which is its main energy
source you have mitochondria in your
cells including your neurons which which
use ATP adenosine triphosphate from your
food as the energy source but when it
uses it it becomes ADP and AM P so
basically you have three phosphates
those in triphosphate and this is broken
down into diphosphate and mono phosphate
so two into one and in order to reuse
that they need to be recombined and
that's what creatine allow these do it
allows you to reuse that kind of waste
from your energy so you get just a
little bit more energy of entry it has
to find other ways of getting energy to
your body which it does through pumping
oxygen around your body but just for the
short term this gives you that little
bit of extra energy which can help you
to get a couple of extra reps in the gym
also adds water attention to your
muscles so you look stronger but
moreover it also increases your
attention because you've got a little
bit more energy in your brain so you can
focus for longer so that's a really good
one and it's been shown to be protective
against a range of neurodegenerative
diseases so great also and make a free
fish oil which is healthy in all kinds
of ways but the main reason I like it
for the brain it's also it's great
antioxidants again it's protective but
the main reason like for the brain is
that it can increase cell membrane
permeability what this means is it your
brain is made mainly of fat actually and
the fact that you eat is the fat ends up
in your brain omega-3 is a good type of
fat for yourself to be made out of
because it's flexible and it allows
things to pass through such as the
neurotransmitters such as the signal so
it actually increases the speed of your
force and again studies have shown that
it can boost memory it can please focus
attention I keep performance and again
it's really good for you
long-term for preventing things like
Alzheimer's etc so another really good
one to use and it has other benefits as
well you can get it from fish if you
want to get from your diet a ton of tuna
next up coconut oil this contains a
certain type of fat called medium chain
triglycerides which the body processes
in a certain way and what you need to
know is it basically gives you immediate
energy straight to the blood and at the
same time it increases your production
of ketones which is the kind of energy
you get when you're fasting which your
brain actually prefers this energy to
glucose for certain functions so
basically what you're doing is you're
giving yourself a sudden shot of useful
energy again it's a very good fat and at
the same time it increases the amount of
an omega-3 fatty acid in the important
parts of your brain it doesn't contain
omega-3 but it increases omega-3 so
these are synergistic they work nicely
together
then we've got lutein this is an
interesting one because I'm actually
experimenting with this I read a study
recently about looting boosting the
amount of a.m. P in the brain ampk which
is adenosine monophosphate let's see
I've gotta wind down
I did well remembering a lot
printing TNA's something along those
lines basically this increases your
performance of your mitochondria or at
least it has been shown to enlighten
this one recent study when taken with
milk full fat milk which aids with the
digestion I don't know whether it
definitely works but I wanted to review
it and I think it is working for me
actually they found that when they gave
this to the mice they were able to run
much farther of their own freewill
suggesting they had much more energy and
they also lost fate lost fat as a result
of that and I thought it could work in a
similar way to creatine that it would
also be able to boost your brain
function as a result and it's since I've
been taking these that I've gone up to
being able to write 20 to 30,000 words a
day from my main copywriting jobs so it
seems good I can't promise it's not a
placebo but if you want to read more
about it visit my blog then I'm taking
bit of indie which is a vitamin and
obviously but it also works very much
like a hormone and it regulates your
release of a lot of other hormones
specifically those relating to sleep
take a shot that morning most of us
don't get enough vitamin D if we live in
the UK because it is miserable out here
as you may know you get bitumen to your
body produces it when it's stimulated to
by the Sun so yeah I'm taking this time
I believe it's eating my sleep as a
result and finally I haven't got the pot
here but I also like garlic extract
because it's a vasodilator meaning it
makes the blood vessels wider allowing
more blood and more oxygen and more
nutrients to get to the brain I'm also
interested in experimenting with Si q10
but I'll write about that when I've
actually given it a go because coenzyme
q10 yeah so that's my new tricks stack
and it doesn't have this kind of
immediate buzzing effect that some
people like to get from things like
modafinil but to me if you're really
trying to boost your brain you don't
want to buzzing your fader like if
you're going for a buzzing effect you're
actually looking for something different
I'm sorry what you want is just slow
steady general brain improvement and if
you combine this with brain training and
I like to use a bit of cognitive
behavioral therapy which I believe can
be used for increasing your brain
performance to optimal level not just
treating mental disorders but again read
about it on my blog a better sleep X
exercise is fantastic by the way it's
been shown to stimulate neurogenesis the
growth of new brain cells as I was
talking about in all the important areas
it helps you to increases the number of
mitochondria which are the things I was
saying the energy centers of your brain
so that gives you more more ability to
feel awake you ever get that feeling
where you just like you're trying to do
a math song and you know you probably
could do it but you just can't quite be
bothered to carry that number across or
you just can't quite be bothered to
focus on what that person saying it's
good even brains out of energy so you
want to give your brain more energy
that's what's going to give you the
ability to really improve your
brainpower in ways that kind of have
noticeable results practical practical
applications say yeah exercise is
fantastic for that and it also increases
your vo2 max your but if take oxygen
into your blood and get it to your brain
so for all these reasons exercise is
fantastic and I'm also experiment with
other things like like therapy I do all
these things but again you can read
about it on my blog I like brain
training games I've made one of my own
called debugger brain and training so
check out in the Google app store if
you're interested brain training apps
and games and general haven't been
proven to be particularly effective but
actually general computer games have
been shown to be really good for your
brain so give days ago but basically
focus on getting the right nutrients and
minerals to make your brain faster and
to protect your cells and that's how
you'll give yourself better brain power
much more efficient much safer than
boosting nootropics which is essentially
I think something people do because they
want an escape they want some kind of
they want to get away from their usual
selves so I really think a lot of people
unfortunately those for the wrong
reasons I'm not saying they have a place
I would consider using something like a
sill tip like I said when I'm just when
I really need a bit of focus but you
just use it on occasion and I still
drink loads of caffeine because I love
tea and coffee and I'm probably dicted
but hey again you can read about that on
my blog all these things that I've
recommended a complete safe they're also
great for fat loss and things like that
again read about it on my blog it would
be better if you got it from your diet
but here's the thing it's really
difficult to get this this made good
things from your diet when you're trying
to live on a budget I mean just eating
tons of
vej is fantastically a brain but free
goes off over time and it's expensive
and yeah and it's also full of sugar say
there's all these issues around it and
that's why I do use supplements it's
just easier unfortunately eating protein
is also very good for your brain so you
could consider my protein shake to be
another one also I think amino acid
supplements have definitely got a place
but I'm going to be looking at that
again more on future so this has been a
23 minute diatribe on nootropics
I hope you found it useful I even know
that follow some of what I've said I'm
sorry if I've babbled on a little bit
and wasn't sure how much information to
give versus just getting down to it
maybe I'll do a simpler version of this
in the future but if you found it
interesting or if you have any questions
whatsoever please let me know in the
comments thank you very much for
watching and if you're watching this
shortly after I upload it then Merry
Christmas and a Happy New Year I'll see
you next time thanks very much and bye
for now